people argue if social medium matters or
if there's such a thing as personal
brand I'm not even gonna get into the
personal brand being a subject matter
because clearly there is I mean I still
see Davy Jones from the Monkees doing
commercials I mean what is he building
off of he's not playing music on that
bullcrap once you build brand equity in
America that is the game I mean really
personal brand is here it's here to stay
I mean what does Oprah do she talks I
mean personal brand is clearly
monetizable I mean what happened with uh
Paul Newman's you know a villa show him
just passed away um you know why do
people buy his lemonade not because of
any other reason because of the personal
brand and then of course the content had
to be good if it was crap s lemonade
nobody would come back so you gotta have
both but what I want to talk to you
about today is word of mouth it's not
that personal brand change or
personality's now claim to be personal
brand that is relevant what is changed
so dramatically and is so important to
me and Chris Mott and every single other
person out there is that word of mouth
has fundamentally changed building
brands and building businesses has
always been about word of mouth go speak
to Grandpa Thompson and he will tell you
word of mouth is where it's at that's
what you do that's what you want you
want people to favorably talk about your
product your service your business that
has always been the most powerful in it
you don't listen to the billboards or
the radio ads or the commercials huh you
listen to somebody else your friend who
you trust
told you it rocked the house that's why
you went but here's where gets powerful
word of mouth has fundamentally changed
to the last three years because of
social media Twitter and Facebook and
other products that like that have
allowed your voice to go extremely viral
so let's just say ma Chris mod over here
was the biggest socialite in New York
City and he just went to every event
every night he was the biggest Yenta in
town how many possible people could he
really tell about your service or that
he liked you or he liked your restaurant
or your business or your wine how many
five hundred a thousand if that's all he
did for a month well now one press of
the bun on Twitter after you type a
couple hundred forty characters and tens
of thousands of people are gonna know
and you think Twitter's big now wait to
real people get on there
I mean god bless me and Scoble and you
know calcaneus and my Clarington kevin
rose but wait - the whole world finds
out about it and Paris Hilton and
Lindsay Lohan start twittering out to
hundreds of thousands of people that
they're at this club you'll see the
power of word mouths word of mouth is
unsterile - my friends it's Roger
Clemens
it's very bonds it's little Brett Boone
in there it is absolutely on steroids
more and more tools are being created
every day to allow your word to travel
in so many more places Plus understand
word about so now you tweet something
else well then so many blog posts about
and then somebody stumble upon that and
then somebody digs that the word the
tail of word of mouth is the power of
what the Internet has created and as
sooner you understand that the sooner
you will understand how to build brands
on the Internet in 2008/2009 and beyond